>>Teacher: Whoa, we have
like, too many people.
>>Student: Check that.
>>Teacher: We have GameMaker
on a couple of flash drives.
>>Narrator: The seemingly chaotic
fun scene is actually a carefully
monitored learning environment,
where advanced students
from McKinley High School are paid
to teach others how to
play and build games.
>>My name is Rick Kelsey, and
my position her at McKinley,
is STEM Director, which is Science,
Technology, Engineering and Math.
I'm also the Director of The
Institute of Urban Game Design,
which is a program
funded by George Mason,
and the National Science
Foundation, where we've taught
over 1,000 students from 150
different schools, around Washington,
D.C., Maryland and Virginia,
and they've all learned how
to make video games, with computer
science, 3D modeling, and animation.
>>Student: The little icon above it.
>>Kevin: We are looking at using
collaboration and mentoring as a part
of delivering and teaching
STEM content.
Typically, you would have an
instructor who may have 20 students
in a classroom, and it's difficult
for that one instructor
to serve 20 students.
So what we've done is,
we've trained students
who are already familiar
with the technology.
>>Justin: This object right
here, this clown, it would have--
>>Kevin: In the summer, we actually
take them through a two week session,
where we teach them
how to become mentors,
provide support, give
them encouragement.
And so we have a cadre of
mentors that are then positioned
in the classroom to
assist the instructors.
>>Justin: So hit F5.
>>Kevin: From our preliminary
results, what we are seeing,
is that on both sides,
we see benefits.
Students are benefiting because
they get immediate feedback,
immediate assistance.
>>Student: Save this right now,
and save it in any file you want.
>>Kevin: The mentors are benefiting
because they are continually
rehearsing and going over skills
that they have learned,
because you know,
you don't really learn something
until you have to teach it.
>>Student: I clicked him.
>>Student: But you
haven't added the code yet,
so nothing is going to happen.
>>Student: Those are just
different shortcut menus.
>>Alice: I just love this idea
of students becoming more
specialized in something.
From early on, knowing that
becoming more specialized
in any field will lead to getting
paid, and getting paid even more,
so it's a great part of the model.
>>Gary: How you doing?
>>I started out as a parent
volunteer, and I was there
when the program was in its infancy.
I saw the value of the program
immediately in his enthusiasm
with regard to his homework.
I got more and more involved, so
I would man the desk, for roll,
I'd tell the kids to stop running
in the hallway, I'd go get snacks,
I'd do whatever it took, just
to keep the program going.
And now I've been instrumental
in helping the D.C. Public School
System roll out a technology bus,
where we can take STEM programs
and education to the students,
and not only just to the
students, but to our citizens.
>>Narrator: The bus
will soon be outfitted
with computer workstations
and flat screen TVs.
Today, students use laptops
to test a new version
of the NSF funded game,
called, "Immune Attack."
>>Chris: This game has a lot of
educational value packed in it,
because I'm not a biology
major, and I'm learning things
by playing "Immune Attack."
This is so detailed, first of
all, it talks about monocytes,
and things in the body that
most people don't know about.
And they've integrated
it into a video game.
It's a great way to learn.
>>Justin: It was an ear infection
you're trying to destroy,
there are these little green-- I
think that's one of them right there.
>>Kevin: Many of our
mentors are tech savvy.
They already know the software,
they're great with the technology,
and so their natural
inclination is to just do it.
>>Justin: It's different
when you explain the game,
than when you're actually, like,
playing it, because I'm trying
to just tell her, and if I got
on, I could just do it, but--
>>Kevin: So we have to say, no,
you don't want to do it for them,
you want to make this student have
success, and you want to push them
or guide them in that way,
but if you just do it,
then they don't have a chance to
see that they can do it themselves.
>>Justin: But you'll know
when you see them, they're--
>>It's just kind of
interesting that--
you feel good, when
you're able to, like,
kind of teach someone something,
and to feel passion about that.
>>Careful, careful, careful.
>>Student: I'm doing it.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.